let me press one that a little further
since you have a y-chromosome here and i
think they're be you know some men
watching whether here or on youtube who
will think hey you know this isn't my
fight I don't have a clitoris and what
and and the same thing I think applies
to a lot of other women's rights issues
what do you say to them is this their
fight or not oh it absolutely is a fight
if they care at all about you know human
rights about their own freedom and their
own dignity i mean i think that that was
my point about the linkage between the
fight for women's rights and the fight
for all human rights I mean it's not we
all can very easily draw the draw the
connections between the status of women
in any particular society and the
general status of human rights in that
society and that includes the societies
in which many of the people who are
watching this this discussion live in so
far as and in its experience of my own
my own life and my own my own
organization that it was the struggle of
women for their rights that made us
understand our own our own rights and
the way things are connected and and the
way that the approach we were taking was
a very narrow and very limited approach
so I think it's it's in the vital
interest of every man and we of course
don't live in isolation from women you
know we have daughters we have wives we
have lovers we you know it's
inconceivable to me that someone could
say this is not of any interest to me
because I'm a male and this happens to
women anymore that I would expect women
to say I'm not really interested in what
happened to Nelson Mandela because he
was a man and I'm a woman I mean what
kind of world is that where we suddenly
divide our feelings about maybe one way
thinking of it is that the Holocaust
attend today wasn't a Jewish you civil
rights weren't a black issue and FGM
isn't just a women's issue like exactly
and I
particularly met men pay such a huge
part in the communities that practice
this as an asst said because one of the
key reasons for FGM being in place is it
makes a girl murrah jable and when as
part of these community conversations
the men come together and decide that
they will marry an uncut woman this is
how it changes within a generation and
you then move to the next community
which is the intra Marian group so men
are so vital in this debate and
particularly as religious leaders as
well and I think when we focus on rights
we get stuck when we focus on economics
which is really what this all comes down
to is kind of what's a girl worth and is
this about marrying her for her value it
changes I think because it's girls
people do react differently than women
so I think that's going to help bring
more people to the issue we've used
economic incentives in a number of cases
to get communities to think differently
about early marriage and the consequence
of the man finally having a reason to
stop and think about his daughter
marrying early or marrying late when
there's an economic incentive to do so
and in the case in Ethiopia a girl who
stays in school is eligible for a sheep
or a goat for her family if she stays in
school two more years the father's have
been saying hmm I wasn't really in the
conversation before I had no reason to
have the conversation I no reason to
think about it had no reason to think
about the value my daughter could bring
to my family if she stayed in school
longer the economic incentive got him to
pay attention so I I'm for the hybrid
solution which is the community Lee
listening incentives where where we can
or we can apply them and I know not
everybody loves incentives but I think
they do work and and the external
pressure